pas spécialement pas spécialement ma
femme moi j'étais un des combats de ma
vie donc je ne vois pas pourquoi je
renoncerais c'est pas le sujet et puis
d'abord ce ce programme il est très
vaste mais moi je pense qu'il faut pas
lâcher sur le communautarisme que
c'était un point majeur oui vous l'avez
proposer des choses là dessus déjà non
j'attendais de vous voir mais comment
mais j'ai plein de choses à dire
là-dessus bien triste comment luttons
contre le communautarisme
eh bien il faut d'abord commencer par
lutter contre les ghettos quand vous
avez des quartiers qui ne sont composés
que de tours où vous avez 100 % de
logements sociaux
vous vous n'y trouvez qu une seule et
même catégorie de population qui sont
généralement des communautés issues de
tel ou tel pays qui sont des pays
d'immigration qui sont venus en france
et bien forcément vous créez du
communautarisme c'est à dire une espèce
de sentiment de comportement dans son
ensemble de gens qui pensent que les
règles de leur communauté sont
supérieures aux lois de la république
bon eh bien moi je pense que il faut
préserver
l'attachement à une communauté ça pose
aucun problème on a tous un attachement
personnel à sa communauté à ces
communautés d'ailleurs religieuse
politique sportive géographique c'est
pas un problème dès lors que l'on
accepte bien que les règles de sa
communauté sont subordonnées aux lois de
la république si ce n'est pas le cas là
ça devient du communautarisme est mon
combat il est de dire mélangeons nous un
peu veillons à se respecter à se parler
et à s'écouter et pour ça il faut plus
qu'on ait peur les uns des autres donc
il faut le prérequis de la sécurité
deuxième prérequis déghettoïser donc
casser ces fameuses tours qui enferme
les gens dans des véritables prisons des
chutes de fête et veillons à avoir
suffisamment d espace public pour que
les gens puissent se rencontrer sans
avoir peur les uns des autres